I was going to make this video earlier
but it made more sense to hold off and
wait for house the dragon to end because
I'm curious where it would fit in in
comparison to Every Game of Thrones
season I've also done an in-depth
analysis review on each season of Game
of Thrones so it finally makes sense to
rank them season eight it comes as
absolutely no surprise that season 8 of
Game of Thrones is at the bottom of my
ranking even season 7 which isn't good
on its own still Far and Away outshines
season 8. this season isn't just bad
with an onslaught of atrocious dialogue
character turns idiotic plot beats bad
editing and incomprehensibly dumb
moments it's also just flat out
insulting like I could be someone at
peace if the final season was just bad
in the mediocre since like season 7 but
so many major story beats are so
completely brain dead to the point that
anyone with a pencil and two brain cells
could do a better job Daenerys is sudden
and unjustified turn despite being in a
winning scenario brand becoming King
because he has a good story butchering
Jaime's entire Arc in one sentence the
egregious amount of plot armor on
display installing a worse form of
government than before I mean I could go
on for like five minutes of just listing
[ __ ] out season 8 makes my blood boil
and the second I Revisited it's like
reigniting a wildfire explosion in my
mind where I remember all the heaps of
trash that's within the season and it
completely sucks that the rest of the
show is so amazing because it's hard to
recommend this show now hey watch this
excellent show that has one of the worst
ending seasons in history I'm sure
you'll love it smile and it even ruins
rewatch potential because knowing that
everything leads to this dumbass
smirking at me while becoming king is
not worth the time there are very few
redeeming qualities about this season
like Brienne getting ignited but it's
really hard to remember that from it
drastically getting overshadowed by all
the horrendous material in the season I
genuinely don't know how David and Dan
can write a season so badly while also
having extra time to do so and the only
answer I can think of is them wanting to
leave ASAP to corn on quote work on
better things despite getting dropped by
Disney for their Star Wars project so
get rolled David and Dan the north
remembers
season seven yeah these two first
rankings are pretty much given since
season 7 and 8 are by far the two worst
seasons in the show because at least
Seasons five and six have some bigger
redeeming qualities than season seven
like the only thing I can think of is
some of the character work at times is
alright to good and The Spoils of War
was a pretty fun action sequence despite
some hiccups in the writing but that's
really it looking towards the latter
part of the Season we have the
completely absurd Voyage Beyond the Wall
to capture a white plot line and then
trying to convince Cersei to help them
in fighting the undead the fact that the
last three episodes hinge on the
singular plan pretty much ruins the
season leading up to that point it was
mostly mediocre but the Beyond the Wall
sequence is shockingly dumb like what
were David and Dan smoking not only do
our main characters have to pull off a
miraculously impossible Heist that
should have gotten them all killed but
they also have to persuade Cersei who is
notoriously stubborn about helping
people let alone her enemy and the fact
that this planet has come coming from
Tyrion is the funniest part of all of it
the smartest character in the show
reduced to arguably one of the dumbest
in the show I honestly wouldn't be
surprised if Hodor was smarter at this
point I'm about to step into a room with
the most murderous woman in the world
who's already tried to kill me twice
that I know of who's an idiot like why
wouldn't his grand plan have Daenerys
fly everyone in and out when capturing a
Wyatt did they think they would get all
the way back to the wall uncontested let
alone doing the plan to begin with
because everyone involved should have
known the outcome regardless so the
execution of Beyond the Wall was
obviously terrible and the finale was so
underwhelming because it accomplished
nothing the only thing it accomplished
was making Jaime mad and leaving and
that was really it Dave and Dan just
wanted to get every character on screen
together but had no idea what that
reason would be for looking at the first
few episodes of the season they are
pretty competent even though there are
still some dumb aspects like euron's
Fleet teleporting around and Varys not
knowing about it the tyrells having
virtually no military strength in the
population of King's Landing suddenly
being really friendly to name a few
issues but this is balanced out by some
good scenes like lady olen's badass
death and some reunions so it's not an
entirely miserable experience like
season 8 was
season five
this may be a little bit of a shock but
I like season six a little bit more than
season five because there are still some
aspects of season six that are pretty
enjoyable the main issue with season
five as I pointed out in my analysis is
that the entire season is really dull
most main characters are faced with
boring conflicts like the introduction
of The Sparrows sons of the harpy and
the sand snakes these conflicts to me
are inherently more interesting in
season six because we experienced their
payoff which was better than their build
up then other main characters like Sansa
Arya and Tyrion have arguably the least
interesting journey in the show this
season sounds like it's pawned off by
Littlefinger to Ramsay for literally no
reason and in the process alienates the
most valued possession that he loves at
one point George R Martin said that
Littlefinger would never do that in his
books because rightfully so it breaks
his character and as a result of all
this nonsense we get a dumb plot line of
Sansa getting tormented Arya starts her
training to be a faceless assassin and
for all the hype to get there I'd much
rather be back with a Hound in Seasons
three and four because holy [ __ ] her
scenes in the house of black and white
are so boring and meaningless that it
chips away at my soul so many of her
scenes revolve around doing nonsense
chores that don't teach her anything and
it's so clear that she's lying about
being no one then for Tyrion Dave and
Dan have clearly shown that they have no
idea how to write an intellectual
character so they just evolved into
turning most of his dialogue into
comedic relief his Dynamic with Varys
becomes insufferable and what was once
an intriguing discussion between two
smart peers becomes an annoying married
couple who are constantly bickering
can't remember the last face I saw that
wasn't yours it's a perfectly good phase
I'm losing my mind when Terry meets up
with sarjora the dialogue gets more
interesting but this journey is still
drastically outclassed by anything in
King's Landing looking at the peak of
season 5 we have heart home and the
climaxes that happen at the end of the
season like it's really hard to remember
much from the middle of this season and
the death of Sir Barrison was truly the
first moment the show made a major
mistake but hardhome definitely recovers
the season a bit and the conclusions for
Daenerys Jon Snow and Cersei were great
the same can't be said for Stannis
Baratheon though one of the more cool
and badass characters goes out with such
a whimper and his whole journey felt
very underwhelming although the death of
serene was a definite highlight overall
season 5 is alright but has a lot of bad
material like the sand snakes that weigh
the season down a lot
season six if it wasn't for all the
crazy payoff within the season like the
Hodor Revolution the battle of the
bastards and the entirety of the Winds
of Winter then I would probably put this
season at the same bar as season five
however this season has the lucky
circumstance of season five doing a lot
of the heavy lifting of dredging through
the mediocre plot lines like The
Sparrows and the sons of the harpy so we
can get to the payoff because the trial
of the seven sequence was easily one of
the best scenes in the show but the same
can't be said for most sequences like
the siege of marine and how idiotic the
Master's plan was to assault Daenerys
who has a much stronger Army and Dragons
but at least I got her closer to leaving
and going to Westeros season six to me
is just inherently more interesting than
season five Arya is now overcoming a
more interesting conflict Tyrion is in a
position that contests his abilities
despite him being very dumb Cersei isn't
locked away in a Cell for half the
season bran is actually present and we
get backstory for the three-eyed Raven
and Jamie doing anything else other than
wandering around and Dorne is an upgrade
and Jon has to overcome Ramsey in a
climactic and epic battle the main
downside for this season is that these
more interesting plot lines are bogged
down by Dave and Dan's notorious bad
writing more so than season five from
the battle the bastards including major
contrivances Arya becoming Immortal
tyrion's dialogue and intellect falling
further into the abyss of stupidity in
Sansa trusting Littlefinger after
everything he has done to her are just a
few things I can think of off the top of
my head this may all sound very damning
but you have to remember that season 6
is very inconsistent in terms of quality
you have all these issues that are then
accompanied by scenes that range from
good to great so even though season 6
has bigger lows than season 5 I think
the season simultaneously has bigger
highs that are more alluring
House of the Dragon season 1.
I think this is the most agreed upon
placement for House of the Dragon to be
in because on one hand it's really close
to matching the quality of the first
four seasons of Game of Thrones while on
the other it's much better than the
later Seasons Dave and Dan really
struggled to write dialogue that was of
the same caliber of George RR Martin's
meanwhile in House of the Dragon I think
they did a great job with the dialogue
and it perfectly Blends into the quality
standards that fans expect from this
franchise at no point in my physically
cringing from how stupid the lines are
and the characters feel fully realized
by the writers they're so riveting and
since we have a more condensed focus on
a smaller amount of characters House of
the Dragon was able to create some
outstanding dramatic moments without a
lot of spectacle because going into the
show I thought it was going to be
heavily reliant on action in Dragon VFX
but the first season instead focuses
more on building characters and the
conflict between all of them this is
essentially the core DNA of what makes
Game of Thrones work so well so it's
really nice to see it be focused on here
I was very close to putting House of
dragon over the next placement but there
were a couple aspects that held it back
which were the excessive time jumps some
wonky moments in the writing and the
ramifications of speeding through the
story too fast despite all the negative
reviews calling the show boring I
actually think the show should have
taken more time however it's
understandable that they didn't want to
exceed 10 episodes so they did the best
they could do on a comparison basis for
the first four seasons of Game of
Thrones I think the biggest aspect that
got has over Hot D is that the story is
more of a roller coaster with tons of
twists and major Revelations while the
first season of House of the Dragon is
like a hydraulic launch that is about to
propel you into the craziness that is
yet to come Hot D is easily a great
addition and I hope the next season has
the strength to break through the
quality of the first four seasons
season two
out of the first four seasons season two
is towards the bottom for me because
there are some issues I have with it and
I'll Focus primarily on them for this
segment but keep in mind that the
writing in every dialogue scene still
exudes a staggering level of quality so
even though I'm going to be focusing on
some of the negatives this is still in
my top four there are two major plot
lines that weigh the season down which
are Daenerys hanging out in carth and
John company wandering around north of
the wall for these two plot lines in
comparison to where their stories are in
seasons one three and four they are
drastically outclassed because for those
other Seasons Jon and Danny go through
massive Journeys that thoroughly develop
them as characters and thus also
accompanied by great conflict to push
them to change then looking at one more
negative aspect is that the budget for
season 2 still wasn't that large yet so
the Battle of the Five Kings didn't
really feel like a battle happening
throughout Westeros so many scenes were
skipped over because the budget for the
show simply wasn't big enough yet the
scope and skill because of this were
weren't able to be achieved at their
Highest Potential David and Dan only had
enough money to do the black water
battle which that battle on its own was
outstanding just imagine if they didn't
have to cut out any battles this season
and actually showed Rob start going on a
conquest thus making him even more of a
badass and a likable character now for
season 2 this wasn't a crippling issue
because of the fact that every scene
that replaced the more expensive ones
were still pretty good the dialogue
scenes were entrancing and gave every
character deep development along with
showing varying perspectives and
philosophies associated with each
character my favorite of the bunch is
between Tyrion and Cersei there's so
much subtext to be mined from their
relationship due to their Rich history
together that makes every scene they
have very insightful and intriguing then
you can basically apply that fact to
every other dialogue scene because the
world of Game of Thrones is so layered
that you're constantly either learning
about the character or the world to some
degree from that character's perspective
making the story constantly riveting and
I haven't even gone into the masterful
Blackwater sequence that was perfectly
built up with great tension and rocking
a perfect execution of a spectacle and
gritty violence even with some of season
2 shortfalls and the fact that the plot
doesn't pop off as much as other Seasons
it still manages to be an excellent
season of Game of Thrones
season three now this is extremely hard
and I can honestly interchange any of
the next three seasons because of how
magnificent they all are but just barely
I'm going to put season 3 under seasons
one and four because those seasons are
essentially perfect the only flaws I
have was season 3 are the anticlimactic
Battle of yunkai Theon getting tortured
All Season became a little repetitive in
the King's Landing narrative to me is
weaker than the other three first
Seasons not saying it's bad in any way
and it's still really good the political
dance between Tywin and Elena as they
manipulate their children on its own is
amazing but to me the death of Ned Stark
the Blackwater and the chaos of season
four outshines that ever so slightly and
honestly we'll come down to preference
as to which one of those narratives is
your favorite but yeah those are really
the only negative things I can think of
because there are so many great aspects
to be enjoyed from the best scene in the
show of the right wedding Jaime losing
his hand and having his bath monologue
Danny acquiring the unsullied Tywin
exploding on his children and Jon Snow
Romancing Yeager at all season leaves no
dull moments for season three every
plotline is extremely entertaining I
think the Red Wedding alone would push
the season to the top of some of your
rankings and I can totally understand
that George R Martin somehow one-upped
one of the biggest Swiss knit
entertainment and this time it's even
more shocking an entire plotline that we
perceived as being in the main one just
comes to a complete stop I don't think
that has ever happened before because at
least the death of Ned Stark wasn't the
complete ending to a whole plot line
this is also to me the best season for
Daenerys she's finally accumulating a
lot of power and it's such a fun ride as
she tears through essos this is where
she becomes an iconic character season 3
has so many great scenes to the point
that I wouldn't be surprised if this is
your favorite season
season one this season will always be
very close to my heart from how expertly
executed it all was all of the dancing
Exposition and setup for every character
is never tedious and you're always
engaged by the electrifying story that
immediately grabs your attention the
fact that the first season of a show is
one of the best is such a hard feat to
pull off George R Martin engrosses us
with a captivating mystery that is laced
with so many plot twists to the point
that we can't stop watching like once we
get to the fourth episode the pace of
the show quickly picks up and you can't
stop yourself although that could be the
case for the first episode too with bran
getting eated out of a window the even
crazier part is that the main plotline
in King's Landing is accompanied by
equally great stories with Jon Snow
Daenerys and Tyrion the Night's Watch
offers a great contrast being said in
the north and this little buildup of
camaraderie between the brothers is so
endearing Daenerys finding her identity
in becoming a leader paired with a
tragic fate of Khal Drogo cements this
world as not being plagued by Cheap
writing and then Tyrion has a
consistently exciting journey across
Westeros any of the plot lines in this
season are always fun to watch the only
reason why I wouldn't put this season at
my top spot is that the season does have
to get the ball rolling as opposed to
later Seasons where they come in
swinging right out of the gate it is a
wild ride from start to finish that
initial barrier of getting everything
going holds the season back as smidge
and in the grand scheme of things it's
really not a big deal considering that
it's in my second spot because the death
of Ned Stark propels this season to
astronomical Heights even knowing about
that to us when starting the show I was
still completely floored by what the
ramifications meant in the story just
absolutely genius story Direction in
general
season four it's a bit of a spoiler that
I put in my season 4 analysis that it's
the best season if you think that season
1 was a wild ride then season 4 Just UPS
it in all regards because Justin King's
Landing alone may go from the out of
nowhere brutal death of Joffrey tyrion's
iconic trial speech that he won in me4
Oberyn coming in from Left Field to
declare himself for tyrion's Champion
oprahan getting his head smashed in
after we thought he won and then Tyrion
killing his love and his father in one
season let alone the rest of what
happens in the season almost every
episode is packed with an absolute
Banger of a plot point that you were
constantly floored by how the season can
stay this amazing like even with Oberyn
declaring himself or Tyrion the episode
still continues and ends with
Littlefinger pushing Lysa Aaron through
the moon door I look at each of the last
five episodes and they all have some of
my favorite scenes in the entire show
and that's not to say that the first
five episodes don't have anything great
going for them either like we have the
Hound rolling people for chicken
Daenerys seizing Marine Jon killing the
mutineers at craster's keep and
obviously Joffrey choking on some pie it
feels like every episode has an orgasmic
climax that sends my brain on a dopamine
parade then this is arguably some of the
best arcs for our characters like Tyrion
Arya and Jon Tyrion hits his lowest
point and nothing holds him back from
unleashing all his anger arya's Journey
with the Hound is a surprising Delight
as she slowly comes to grow a fondness
for him as a father figure of sorts the
fact that the Hound even shares the
sentiment by the end marks a great end
point for his overall character Arc and
then Jon has a massive moral dilemma in
which she has to protect his brothers
from the wildlings despite him actually
agreeing with their cause and having
personal stakes in them with egrets this
isn't even mentioning that the Watchers
on the walls in this season which is by
far my favorite episode in the show some
of the best action dialogue set pieces
and heart-wrenching character moments
can be found in this episode I feel like
I can start any episode in this season
and immediately become entranced by the
immense quality that each one has I love
season 4 and there might be a couple of
small flaws here and there like the
terrible editing and the Hound and
brienne's fight scene but the story
Peaks here on almost every front to the
point that they don't matter thank you
for watching and let me know in the
comments what your ranking of the
seasons is